so what's it feel like to be ruining the
best city in America so what are you
still doing in San Francisco if you're
not working in tech so how come you
haven't just moved to Oakland guess what
I can't I call it San Fran Yoli thought
the Taurus people in Seattle would kill
to have a rhyming they know it's San
Francisco so Chris what do you do right
now I'm a legal assistant at a
non-profit I'm a DJ and I write on the
side so are you also like a lyft driver
where did you come in here we help tech
companies all the government actually
okay yeah so like Obamacare so what
hasn't your startup got funded yet can I
have stuff I'm like an angel I invest so
has your childhood home been bought in
and turned into like a Google shuttle
stop yet you proud to live in a city
where a fictional version of the fog has
more Twitter followers than the mayor
how does it feel to be like pushing
everybody else out of the city pushing
everybody else
yeah can you have a tech industry run
another point oh point all right sure
the white people haven't quite moved in
there so what's it like just to always
be cold what's it like just never having
summer I've adapted it's sunny out but
you're wearing a scarf you're wearing
gloves right now you're right fingerless
gloves so you can still catch your phone
right figured out there's no summer
you're getting upset about it I am kind
of upset about it
we're gonna juice cleanse right now it
seemed really happy it was really good
toast but I definitely never paid $7 do
you ever like take a sip of coffee I
think oh yeah this is like the perfect
like coffee blend and then think to
yourself oh my god I'm a big snob what
other kind of pretend snobbery so do you
know anyone wasn't her room
only about nobody get more literate if
we do bee do bus game yeah